onset naps six shots of espresso and
lots of o'doyles it's no wonder phillip
seymour hoffman gave billy madison a
pass
in another universe the talented bob
odenkirk of better call saul and
breaking bad fame would have become a
superstar much earlier in his career
alas while the comedy writer received
plenty of acclaim and goodwill for his
stints on mr show and the ben stiller
show chances are his hollywood ascent
might have gone quite differently had
the executives at universal studios
listen to sandler sandler wanted odin
kirk to play the villainous eric gordon
a role eventually assumed by bradley
whitford at the time odenkirk was mainly
known for his work behind the scenes at
saturday night live where he wrote the
famed motivational speaker sketch for
chris farley that only aired after he
left the gig sandler revealed on the fly
on the wall podcast that the studio
didn't want to simply fill the cast with
friends of the comedian and wouldn't
allow him to cast odenkirk in the role
when sandler's efforts to bring in odin
kirk failed he pivoted in a different
direction after viewing a hilarious
audition tape from then up and coming
actor philip seymour hoffman in the same
interview with dana carvey and david
spade on fly on the wall sandler
revealed that the studio held open
auditions following the odenkirk
rejection sandler caught a glimpse of
hoffman and was absolutely blown away by
what he saw sandler went to the studio
and begged them to hire the man after
much deliberation they finally relented
and agreed only for hoffman to turn down
the part sandler was stunned and decided
to call hoffman himself after explaining
how much he liked his audition for which
hoffman politely thanked him sandler
then said that he had been told hoffman
didn't want the part asked by sandler
why he didn't want to do it hoffman
simply replied ah i just don't want to
hoffman of course would go on to have a
terrific career that saw him win
numerous accolades and was even able to
eventually work alongside sandler in
punch drunk love before tragically
passing away in 2014
one of the funniest scenes in billy
madison involves the titular character
taking part in a game of dodgeball with
a bunch of first graders in his first go
the young kids led by a member of the
dreaded o'doyle clan knocks the grown
man out of the game before he can even
reach the playground after receiving
encouragement from his teacher billy
gives it another go and decides to let
loose and exact some brutal revenge as
the actor recalled on conan during the
scene he hit a couple kids so hard with
the ball that he actually drew tears
from some of them afterwards the
children's parents complained to him
about how hard he was hitting them with
the dodgeball sandler tried to defend
himself with a solid argument but it
didn't go as he planned you know i said
then they read the script they go
there's six they don't read yet
sandler promised not to do it again but
when the cameras rolled he couldn't help
himself and continue dishing out the
punishment as recalled by director tamra
davis in a 2015 article published in the
washington post the kids started crying
as soon as the ball hit them so i had to
cut away before the audience could see
director tamra davis's involvement in
the project came about in an unusual way
in 1994 universal pegged her as its top
choice to helm billy madison and flew
the young director out to meet sandler
davis had helmed a comedy starring chris
rock called cb4 for the studio a year
earlier and the studio was so pleased
with the job she did that they were
eager to work with her once more writing
about the meeting with sandler in an
article for the washington post davis
joked i have a fondness for jewish boys
from new york i'm married to mike d of
the beastie boys and thought our meeting
went well but later heard from the
studio that adam wanted to work with an
old friend according to entertainment
weekly that old friend was stephen
kessler who had helped sandler early in
his career by putting him in a
commercial however two weeks into
shooting the studio removed kessler and
brought davis back sandler explained why
in an interview with entertainmentweekly
saying the studio wanted a less stylized
movie more of me being a goof according
to davis the movie was in serious
trouble and sandler was stressed out as
a result she immediately came in and
changed the set's atmosphere into a more
relaxed environment allowing sandler the
freedom to do what he does best in the
same washington post article davis
explained how she loosened up the set
after coming aboard as director she only
wanted smiling crew members eager to
laugh which would prompt sandler to do
his thing writing i don't think
universal had any idea what adam's style
of comedy really was when they
greenlighted the project and neither did
i sandler's style evidently involves a
lot of improvisation which is why a
majority of the best gags in billy
madison weren't included in the original
script as davis recalled many of the
stranger but most frequently quoted
scenes in billy madison were unplanned i
don't remember the shampoo is better
conversation adam has with himself being
in the script but that was what happened
when adam was loose and having fun other
improvised bits include darker comedic
moments such as when doo doo the clown
falls down and hits his head including
the camera panning down to show a
trickle of blood coming out of his mouth
even the dodgeball scene was a last
second addition thankfully davis was
totally up for this brand of comedy
otherwise billy madison might have
turned out quite differently fans of
billy madison will recall the odd side
characters sprinkled throughout the film
including billy's first grade teacher
with a passion for interpretive dance
the accident prone doo doo the clown and
whoever norm mcdonald was supposed to be
still the best of the best remains chris
farley's angry penguin-loving bus driver
prone to violent sweat-inducing rants
the bus driver steals nearly every scene
he is in mostly due to farley's intense
acting techniques according to an
interview with director tamra davis by
yahoo entertainment farley drank six
shots of espresso to prepare for the
scene with the director recalling and
then he went and did it and he held his
breath until he turned red everybody
else is laughing and i'm gonna have a
heart attack because i'm like the mom
i'm worried he's gonna have a heart
attack davis added that just as he did
with his work on saturday night live
farley was willing to push himself as
far as he possibly could for a laugh
everybody on good great grand wonderful
no yelling on the bus
despite the excellent results that came
about from his intense methods davis
remembered herself thinking oh my god
you don't have to go that far
another nice touch in billy madison is
the inclusion of character actor larry
henkin who appears as carl alfons eric
gordon's right-hand assistant he's quiet
relatively cool and taken more by
billy's all-around nice guy persona than
eric's break the little guy attitude
about midway through the film he
approaches billy and warns him of eric's
treachery adding a little impersonation
of eric for good measure funnily enough
henkin was apprehensive about displaying
his comedy chops as revealed on the
podcast beyond the backlot hankin was
initially hired by the film's original
director stephen kessler after the first
two or three days of filming hankin was
having lunch when sandler called him
over as henkin recalled on the podcast
he's questioning me you know how long
have you been in show business and then
sandler said do you do anything funny
taken aback by the comment pankin
replied that he had a funny face that he
made for children but was too stupid to
do for sandler however sandler pressed
and the actor obliged with the goofy
face and laugh you see in the movie
luckily it makes carl all the more
lovable perhaps the greatest gift billy
madison bestowed upon audiences was the
original adam sandler's steve buscemi
team up although buschemi's part in the
comedy is minor it's incredibly
memorable he plays a former classmate of
billy's who spends his free time
sampling lipstick and hunting the
bullies of his youth and the gig paved
the way for future roles in a number of
sandler films man i'm glad i called that
guy
still despite memorable parts in
everything from the wedding singer to
hubie halloween bushemi actually prefers
billy madison over all else the actor
revealed as much during a reddit q a
back in 2015. a fan asked buscemi which
of his sandler films was his favorite
and the great character actor replied
well i'm very partial to billy madison
because that was one of the first films
adam did on his own as part of his
production company he went on to discuss
meeting sandler on airheads where the
two actors had a great time working
alongside one another leading to the
aforementioned long-running partnership
hushemi closed out his answer by stating
i don't know if i have a favorite but i
do really love the character in billy
madison the world lost a legendary
funnyman when norm mcdonald passed away
the man knew comedy better than most and
had a particular brand of humor that
just worked provided you understood it
that made him an obvious co-star for any
sandler vehicle the pair shared the
screen in a number of projects and
enjoyed a decades-long friendship that
continued until mcdonald's death in
september of 2021 still their greatest
collaboration remains billy madison
where mcdonald had a bit part as one of
billy's slacker friends who spends far
too much time getting drunk by the pool
sandler recalled the experience on conan
with mcdonald and a handful of his
comedian buddies adding his own colorful
commentary for good measure apparently
in one of the pool scenes sprinkled
throughout billy madison sandler's
character is supposed to speak with
mcdonald's character frank sandler said
his line and was surprised when mcdonald
remained quiet at first thinking that
norm was taking his time before
delivering his line sandler realized
that wasn't the case saying after a few
more seconds i noticed ole norm was
sleeping mcdonald chimed in and joked
that since he was playing a drunk in the
film he had asked for some booze so that
he could do some method acting for the
scene he followed that up with another
ridiculous explanation also he called me
frank and in my mind i was thinking
only norm mcdonald could get away with
that one
billy madison fans will likely recall
the o'doyle clan that tormented billy in
every grade these red-headed
mean-spirited bullies with a hilariously
simple catchphrase pick on billy by
dumping chowder on his head and stuffing
his locker with horse manure before the
entire family meets a violent end
this part of the movie can mostly be
attributed to rich wilkes wilkes wrote
airheads and according to vice was hired
by producer robert simmons to do an
uncredited rewrite of sandler and tim
herlihy's billy madison script feeling
that much of the comedy seemed too
episodic he suggested several changes to
straighten the plot out for example the
original script called for a young bully
to frequently appear and torment billy
with a slingshot while sandler and
hurley he came up with the odoil rules
tagline wilkes was the one who came up
with their name in a rather unexpected
way saying i took the name from brian
doyle murray bill murray's brother
because he's one of the funniest guys
ever i added the o because you want the
o'doyles to be instantly recognizable
that's why they're all redheads